one of the gateways to Saxon Switzerland
is Pina it's an attraction in its own
right with the well-preserved old town
center
during the Middle Ages sand stone
quarrying and trade may pair know one of
the wealthiest towns in Saxony
and just like many painters who were
based here in the 18th century
modern-day tourists often set out on the
river ever to explore the romantic
countryside by boat the Saxon Steamboat
Company has been taking visitors to the
many places of interest since 1837 with
its nine vintage vessels it claims to be
the world's oldest and largest fleet of
paddle steamers after just a few
kilometres the distinctive clips so
typical of the region come into view a
Travel Guide from as early as 1846
recommended exploring the region on foot
as the best way to enjoy the scenery the
stone Buster bridge is a highlight of
any walking tour built in 1851 it's an
architectural masterpiece and Saxon
Switzerland best-known landmark from a
plateau nearly 200 metres high there's a
great view of the rocky cliffs and the
Elbe Valley
the basta bridge is just one of the
stops on the main walking route which
extends for 112 kilometers it links
impressive landscapes that inspired
artists more than two centuries ago
and if you want an active vacation the
region is perfect for hiking and rock
climbing in the Bella Valley alone there
are 239 summits to climb many rock
climbers meet here when the weather is
fine
equipped only with ropes and carabiners
according to traditional Saxon rules
they conquer rock formations such as The
Pillars of Hercules
in general the rocks aren't particularly
high that makes the Bella valley
especially popular with beginners and
Families
both sides of the air were in the region
boast castles and palaces conics town
fortress two hundred and forty meters up
on a rocky plateau is especially
striking it's one of the largest hilltop
fortifications in Europe here you can
see one of our remaining cannons of
course they used to be a lot more in
troubled times cannons were placed along
the wall all along the fortress
but conics Tyne never actually came
under attack
vism stein castle is in the mukhlis
valley
you can view the private rooms of prince
johan of saxony including the one where
he translated down to his Divine Comedy
into German
the Barack Gardens at cause said 'let's
also testified to the high ambitions of
Saxony's royals this spacious terraced
gardens are based on Versailles and it's
that mixture of natural and man-made
landscapes that makes it one of
Germany's most popular travel
destinations